ken paxton joins us now general paxton
you just heard the president's
spokeswoman uh calling the busing of
migrants to washington a stunt how do
you see it
you know what it's it's really
interesting that she would say that
we're in a very difficult situation we
have a federal government the biden
administration refusing to enforce
federal law the numbers are are heading
up as you saw from from march numbers
those numbers are going to go up as
title 42 goes away and we're in a very
difficult spot here dealing with crime
dealing with the spread of cove but
dealing with
all kinds of issues economic issues and
and crime issues as the cartels gain
more and more power along the border
you talked about those numbers and i
want to put some of those up on the
screen
encounters during the fiscal year of of
2021 1 million 26
460. that's from october of 21 to march
of 22. so more than a million migrant
encounters at the border more than half
of those 552 000 were actually sent back
across the border because of title 42.
now that is the program that's about to
be dropped the rule that's about to be
dropped
and border patrol is saying you might
see as many as 18 000 migrants a day
trying to
reach this country
yeah under the trump administration i
think the numbers have gone up since
then about 300 percent that was during
the first year of joe biden that's a
pretty massive increase now
if you remove title 42 and
the numbers are 50 i think it's 53 were
sent back under title 42 during the bite
administration add that 53 percent to
the numbers that we've already seen
i don't know how we deal with that i
just know there's going to be more crime
i know the cartels are going to make
more money and there's going to be more
problems for americans not just texans
not just border states literally we're
all border states now yeah some
democratic senators like mark kelly and
joe manchin have said that they think
that it's it's foolish to withdraw title
42
but uh bob menendez senator from new
jersey is not among them listen to what
he has to say
title 42
is being used
to evade
our asylum laws some of my colleagues
who somehow think that it should be
extended are making a huge mistake
because all title 42 does
is it has migrants making multiple
efforts to cross
versus knowing that there is finality in
an adjudicated asylum claim
now to win asylum in the united states
you have to prove either past or the
likelihood of future persecution based
on race or religion or membership in a
particular group the uyghurs in china
for instance could probably uh make it
uh to asylum in the united states if
china would ever release any of them
but most of the people crossing our
southern border are not really eligible
for asylum are they
no and senator mendes what he said was
completely confusing asylum is now used
as a loophole i think it's 12 to 14 of
the people that come across the border
actually qualify for asylum the rest of
them come to the border come to the
border not trying to evade border patrol
but turning themselves in they claim
asylum they get transported by the biden
administration in the middle of the
night whether on bus or by plane all
over the all over the country we don't
know where they're going they don't tell
us and and then they disappear and
supposedly
show up for their hearing two or three
years later which most of them don't
it's a complete loophole everybody knows
it the the the cartels know it the
immigrants know it everybody knows it
well there must be a reason that the
biden administration is allowing this
many illegals to cross the border what
do you think that reason is
i think there's two reasons one is he
sending him mostly republican states it
does it does harm to our states and
second i think that he is hoping that at
some point in the near future he can
give all of them amnesty and they become
a voting bloc for the for the democratic
party that is the only thing that makes
sense everything else that i look at as
it relates to this harms americans it's
risky for the for the immigrants we're
going to have a system where we're going
to have immigrants come let's do it in a
safe way not the way we're doing now
which is the cartels which is is not the
the best people to transport uh
immigrants this is all you know not good
for for americans
a huge number of those who have been
allowed into the country are eligible
for work permits and for those at the
lower end of the economic scale people
working for minimum wage all of a sudden
they've got brand new competition and
lots of it
yeah and i think if you saw this in the
trump administration you had the highest
level of employment for hispanics and
for african-americans and oddly the
really the whole country and it was
because we had a decent immigration
policy that limited new people coming
into the country which were taking jobs
from some of the people that are here so
it is definitely an economic detriment
to a lot of americans who are trying to
make a living
and what in terms of crime that kind of
thing what are you seeing in the border
communities are really
all over texas as a result of this
migration
look we know that that drug overdoses in
the entire united united states are up
over 30 since biden came into office
that's a that's about a hundred thousand
americans dying so we know there's a
direct impact because these border
agents
as good as they are they're so busy
doing logistics we know that they can't
stop the drug trade that the cartels are
pushing for so so we have that we also
know that there's a higher incidence of
crime we know that people on the border
are fearful for their lives they're
fearful for their property it's changing
the way our border communities have to
live one quick question a quick answer
if you would please you're suing to
prevent 42 title 42 from being dropped
do you think you can win
absolutely i think we have a really good
chance just like we do with the asylum
program we have a u.s supreme court case
coming up april 26th i think we're going
to win that as well
attorney general
ken paxton from the state of texas
general paxton thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else